donc si je reviens à la France je crois
qu'on peut se réjouir d'une couverture
très haut très haut débit fixe et mobile
élevé on est devenu vous le savez le je
crois le pays la France en tout cas dans
les grands pays le plus le celui qui est
le plus couvert en terme de de foyer ou
on peut s'abonner à la fibre optique on
a eu un engagement fort des opérateurs
alternatifs il supporte une grande
partie des investissements si on prend
le FTTH 60 % des investissements dans le
FTTH sont faits par les trois opérateurs
alternatifs orange en conservant 40%,
mais c'est une part qui continue à
diminuer donc cet investissement c'est
un investissement lourd parfois on a le
sentiment quand on rencontre des sur le
terrain des des
politiques ou même des entreprises que
la totalité de ces investissements sont
faits pour enregistes sont faits de fait
de manière minoritaire au total par
Orange majoritairement par les
opérateurs alternatifs nouvel entrantes
sur ces sujets
et puis il y a un élément qui est
extrêmement important c'est que la
réalité de la concurrence qui existe en
France fait que nous bénissions vous
l'avez rappelé madame la présidente des
tarifs les plus bas ou parmi les plus
bas en fonction de des cas
en
Europe et si on le ramène au pouvoir
d'achat dans le monde à pouvoir d'achat
équivalent le les États-Unis pratique
des prix 3 à 4 fois plus cher au prix
français donc on a un bilan je pense
d'ouverture à la concurrence 25 ans
après c'était 80 1998 et nous étions la
dès 1998 qui est donc très je pense très
positif